I have to admit the more you talk to
libertarians the more persuasive they
become it's really hard to sort of wear
you down yeah hi I'm Ted bellacor with
reason TV and today i'll be speaking
with filmmaker christina heller heller
is the director of liberto pia a
documentary about the Free State Project
find out how to see the film by visiting
Liberty topia film calm and by becoming
a fan of the movie on facebook christina
give me a thumbnail sketch of what your
films about our film is about certain
individuals involved with the free state
project which is this movement to get
libertarians concentrated in a single
state with a low population in order to
create kind of a strong enough block of
people that they can actually make some
real change as far as freedom in a
single state we follow three people who
are involved with the free state project
on their journeys will the walker is a
guy who's decided to walk cross country
for the sake of liberty this is will
buchanan recording for the watch for
liberty i'm trying to walk at least 21
miles a day now will decided that in
order to gain some publicity for the
free state project he was going to walk
from organ to new hampshire and then
when he got to New Hampshire it was
going to be his move so in the film we
actually literally follow will across
the United States it takes a while for
him to I mean he's a pretty sprightly
Walker and everything but how could he
pull this off financially even will was
a pretty successful computer programmer
which incidentally a lot of libertarians
are computer programmers but he was a
pretty successful computer programmer in
New York City for a long time and you
probably could have kept that lifestyle
going for a while but he realized you
know that this wasn't his passion and
that a comfortable job wasn't worth
sacrificing the things in life that he
truly cared about so he quit his job and
decided that this is what he wanted to
do another fellow you follows Andrew a
young redheaded guy from Los Angeles my
friends are all going to close to so
when you go up in your turn 18 anyone
goes College things change anyways so
we're all doing what we got to do and
this is what I gotta do we'd put out
like a message on youtube if you're
moving to New Hampshire for the free
state project preferably from far away
give us a call and he contacted us and
said he was 18 like fresh out of high
school and that he was going to be
moving to New Hampshire we just thought
that was so interesting you know like
someone so young who was interested in
the cause especially moving from the Los
Angeles area it turned out really really
well as family was so
nice to kind of let us into their world
and we got like a nice view of what
would make an 18 year old want to take
such a drastic move you know ron paul
had played a big role ron paul yeah he
had discovered column starts a ground
ball i first discovered libertarianism
through ron paul i think it wasn't that
he convinced me of anything that i
didn't already believe it was that he
was affirming all the things that I just
knew innately to be true well obviously
a lot of Free Staters as they're called
they're big ron paul fans and in the
film ron paul gets kind of a lot of
little shout outs here and there because
not only is andrew afam but then we'll
all he's walking is wearing the ron paul
had a lot the third guy is matt bearded
matt who used to be a professor I've
been in New Hampshire for almost three
years now and enjoying it to the fullest
I have to tell you especially in people
honk at me and give me the thumbs down
on the side of a road of your three
characters he's the only one who's
already there right right he moved in
2006 he started his own nonprofit the
New Hampshire Coalition for common-sense
marijuana policy so since 2007 he's been
fighting for common-sense marijuana laws
in New Hampshire what we think is kind
of interesting is that in the film you
kind of get people in three different
phases of involvement with the Free
State Project you get Andrew you get to
watch him as he actually moves will you
meet him as before he moves and the
entire journey is before he gets there
and then with Matt you got someone who's
already there so you're kind of getting
this three-stage look at people who are
involved with it and why did you decide
to pursue this project from the
beginning it was a collaboration with me
and my co-producer we were making short
documentaries for current TV in New
Hampshire and we did a piece on the
pride of gun ownership in New Hampshire
for current and then we ended up finding
out about the Free State Project and did
a short for current about the Free State
Project and after we made our short we
realized that there was just so much
more going on with this whole story that
we decided to try to make a future from
it sorry use some flavor of libertarian
well it's interesting that you ask
because honestly at first I wasn't
really a libertarian at first I was
somebody who considered myself socially
liberal and I had never really
considered a lot of you you're halfway
there yeah I would never really
considered the economic side of things
and I have to admit the more you talk to
libertarians the
more persuasive they become it's really
hard to sort of wear you down yeah it's
really hard to deny how much sense it
all makes and so at this point I think
I'm kind of sad to the club I think all
right right on yeah there's a lot of
talk among libertarians about sometimes
they have a reputation of being a little
bit too argumentative did you find that
to be the case I'm frankly encouraged
that they sort of brought you in and oh
no you know I have to say the media
portrays libertarians a lot of times to
be crazy and every person that I meant
that was involved with Free State
Project was not only one of the smartest
people i met but like the nicest these
people who are just so like principled
in their core that manifests in every
every aspect of their life i was really
inspired by them and that's part of the
reason i wanted to do this story is
because i think that a lot of
documentaries focus on what's wrong with
with the world but I meet these people
who are so nice so passionate so smart
who are not cynical they really believe
that they can make change and I decided
that that it was worth you know that was
worth heralding you mentioned media
portrayals of libertarians one of the
more interesting parts of your film is
when you show the open carry folks and I
think that's when a lot of people who
aren't libertarian say OC whack job
whack job but if you really are the
libertarian of course you really believe
that the non initiation of force
principle and so someone who's really
truly a libertarian is in a lot of ways
the last person you should worry about
totally and you'll see in the there's a
there's a scene in the film where we
show a bunch of Free Staters doing some
target shooting and in the beginning of
the scene they go over the gun safety
rules the whole time there's this
emphasis on safety they're very
responsible gun owners I found for the
most part your film as well time because
we're about at the decade mark of the
free state project it was kind of
launched what was it 2001 yell political
scientist the goal was to get what
twenty thousand folks to sign up where
are we now the original concept was that
20,000 would sign up and then they would
all move that way you didn't have to
move unless you knew you had kind of
like a band of compadres around you but
what happened was it was taking a lot
longer to get everyone signed up so
eventually if you
like you know what New Hampshire is a
great place to live I'll just move and
get things started so i think that
there's maybe a little less than a
thousand people now in New Hampshire
who've moved for the Free State Project
libertarians are such a small part of
the population in most states that
you're never actually going to be able
to break into the two-party system and
make any change but if you found a state
with a low population like New Hampshire
there's only a million people in the
whole state plus it already has a
Liberty leaning kind of mentality anyway
live free or die that if you concentrate
a bunch of activists not just normal
people but activists in a state that you
could actually maybe see some progress
have you seen any specific progress
anything moving in the Liberty direction
twelve Free Staters have actually been
elected to office and I think that
that's pretty amazing actually fish
pedicures are still illegal there for
those who don't know that's a practice
that's pretty common in parts of Asia
were little toothless fish basically
give you a pedicure we interviewed this
Vietnamese woman who invested a bunch of
money into this practice and the state
basically shut her down it just shows
how much progress there still is yet to
be made what are some of the things that
people think about when they think of
New Hampshire you can drive your
motorcycle without a helmet no helmet
laws no seatbelt laws i think there's no
seat belt laws that could be wrong about
that there's no seat belt laws for
adults I think they actually have some
of the safest streets in America
elastomer checks they don't have sales
tax or income tax and they were the
first state to legalize civil unions
without being forced to by the judiciary
so I mean they don't have gay marriage
but they were the first state that just
passed it through the house just said
yeah this is the right thing to do and
want to head with it New Hampshire is a
great State for Liberty lovers and I
think that the more people like the Free
Staters who move in the more it will
just become the folks who are there the
Free Staters who are there how do they
regard the movement now are they
thinking that it's better than they
expected are they disappointed or is it
all over the place in terms of opinion
the standard line that I get is that
people who moved to New Hampshire don't
know why they didn't do it
everybody who moves there is actually
really happy to be there and i think is
very optimistic about the the project in
its future
you